hey here's a wild idea why not do aspen
ver Stipe winner fights Jon Jones Tom
Aspen is put in work he's the number one
guy in the world a lot of people favor
him over Jon Jones so you're just gonna
have him wait for how long what what can
you do with Aspen you Haven wait till
Jon's PEC is 100% better and then he has
to fight Stipe and then Aspen fights
that's stupid that's
insane so you have a healthy Stipe
you have the number one guy Aspen all
Jon's out of the picture with the torn
pack they're both chilling St B was
ready to fight ask when I was ready to
fight st's a big name as when I's
getting bigger back up the bags pay both
those boys you go to step bab like all
right you're not getting Jon Jones money
but you're getting you're getting a bag
and if you win you here you go t fight